ينضم الينا من رام الله اللواء الركن
المتقاعد واصف عريقات الخبير في الشؤون
الاستراتيجيه
والعسكريه لواء واصف عريقات ابدا معك من
ما ذكرته نجوان سمري ان الجيش الاسرائيلي
يعزي سبب عدم التقدم في جنوب قطاع غزه الى
الكثافه السكانيه كيف يستقيم هذا المنطق
مع ما نراه على الارض وهو يدمر مبان
بكاملها احياء بكاملها ولا يابها عاده
للسكان
المدنيين يعني بالتاكيد الكثافه السكانيه
لها علاقه ولكن الاهم من الكثافه السكانيه
هو المقاتل الفلسطيني المقاتل الفلسطيني
منذ بدايه العدوان الاسرائيلي على قطاع
غزه ونحن نلاحظ ان هناك تكتيكات يستخدمها
اربكه العدو حقيقه وهذا ان دل على شيء يدل
على ان المهارات الميدانيه والقت اليه
الاعداد والتدريب والتهيئه لهذه المعركه
لم يكن فقط يوم 1710 حينما استطاع
المقاتلين الفلسطينيين على مدار ثلاث
سنوات ان يعدوا انفسهم في مهارات ميدانيه
وقتاليه ومعركه عقول وادم وسيناريوهات
حاكت العدوان
واستطاعوا ان ينفذوا خطه استراتيجيه يوم
1710 حينما استطاع 1200 مقاتل ان يهزموا
1000 20,000 جندي من نخبه النخبه في فرقه
غزه في مواقعها المحصنه ها هم الان نفس
المقاتلين الذين اعدوا نفسهم لعمليه طوفان
الاقصى اليوم يواجهون الجنود الاسرائيليين
الجنود الاسرائيليين ذهبوا الىى قطاع غزه
مسكونين بالصدمه والرعب من يوم 17 مهزومين
نفسيا مهزومين معنويا وحملوا وحملوا هني
بعل بروتوكول هنيال الذي عززه في نفسياتهم
القياده السياسيه خاصه نتنياهو وهو ان
الجندي الاسرائيلي ذاهب الى قطاع غزه اما
قتيلا او اسيرا او جريحا فبالتالي هذه
الروح القتاليه متدنيه عند الجيش
الاسرائيلي نتيجه للعوامل التي تم ذكرها
ومعنويات المقاومين الفلسطينيين مرتفعه
وخاصه انهم يحققون انجازات على الارض هم
الذين يخوضون المعارك وهم الذين وهم الذين
يصورون اشرطه الفيديو كيف يقنصون الجنود
والدبابات وكيف يعني يشاهدون المعنويات
الاسرائيليه ماذا عن الجانب الاخر الجانب
الاسرائيلي نتنياهو يؤكد بان هذه الحرب
ستستمر لاشهر فيما واشنطن بوست تنقل عن
محللين ان اسرائيل تنفق اموالا طائله على
نشر اكثر من
220 الف جندي احتياط في هذه الحرب هل لدى
اسرائيل استراتيجيه واضحه خطه استراتيجيه
واضحه يعني بالتاكيد اكيد نتنياهو
استراتيجيته اطاله امد المعركه مهما كلف
الثمن وهذا بات ظاهرا وخاصه ان الجيش
الاسرائيلي
الان يتهم نتنياهو او ربما يعتقد بان
نتنياهو وضع له هدفا غير قابر للتحقيق
بمعنى القضاء على المقاومه الفلسطينيه
ماذا عن التكلفه الاقتصاديه الى متى هي
قادره على
تحملها يعني بالتاكيد بدا بداوا يتحدثون
عن اقتصاد الح حرب بمعنى ان الكلفه
العاليه هذه لم يتوقعوها وخاصه في مجال
الاسلحه والذخائر حينما نسمع ان الشركات
الاسرائيليه بدات تلغي كل عقودها لبيع
الاسلحه والذخائر واعطت الاولويه لاسرائيل
وان اسرائيل بعد بعد
230 طائره محمله بالذخائر
وبالاسحار الان تشكو من نقص في الذخائر
وتطلب من الولايات المتحده الامريكيه
يعني لانها يعني حقيقه استخدمت كل
احتياطاتها وهذا لا يجوز في العلم العسكري
وخاصه ان هناك احتمالات على فتح جبهات
اخرى القلق الاسرائيلي موجود الان
اقتصاديا وموجود عسكريا وخاصه في مخزون
الاسلحه والذخائر طيب نتحدث عن الرقم 200
200 ال جندي احتياط في هذه الحرب يعني عدد
من الجنود مهول في قطاع غزه صغير مساحه
جغرافيه صغيره بالاضافه الى عدد من
المقاومين يقدرون
بالالاف يعني واضح
انه المدافع وهو المقاوم الفلسطيني ليس
مقاوما عاديا ك كالجنود الذين واجههم
الجيش الاسرائيلي في السابق يعني المقاومه
الفلسطيني يحتاج الى 10 الى 15 جندي
اسرائيلي حتى يستطيعون التعامل معه اي
وهذه حسابات اسرائيل الحاليه ولكن انا
بتقديري زج 22,000 جندي في قطاع غزه هذا
يعني انهم فريسه للمقاومه الفلسطينيه كلما
ارتفع عدد ال الجنود الاسرائيليين في داخل
قطاع غزه هذا يعني عدد اكبر من الخسائر في
صفوف الجيش الاسرائيلي لاحظي اخت فد بعد
ان زجوا الويه جديده في خان يونس واصبحت
سبع الويه بما معناه
فرقتين كان هناك خسائر اكبر من السابق
يعني ارتفع عدد الخسائر
50% فبالتالي اسرائيل تدرك ان زج عدد كبير
من الجنود في في غطاء غزه هذا يعني خسائر
اكبر ويعني اعطاء فرصه للمقاومين
الفلسطينيين باقتناص شكرا لك اللواء الركن
متقاعد واصف عريقات الخبير في الشؤون
الاستراتيجيه
والعسكريه